what is the law related to freedom of
speech in Singapore right because we
have we have the First Amendment so here
in America the government can't take
away your freedom of speech but you said
it before it seems like we're doing it
to ourselves these days in America where
we're picking topics that we don't talk
about but what are there any laws
related to freedom of speech and
Singapore yes some people would say that
the constitute yeah there is a
constitution in Singapore which claims
that there is freedom of speech but it's
our article 14 but in that Constitution
itself it then says class to it then
says oh we have freedom of speech but
there are some restrictions to freedom
of speech even if it you know breaks the
public harmony or the peace or is
provocative or whatever and that
completely defeats the purpose
of freedom of speech that isn't
freedom of speech anymore so the reason
why we have that constitution which
claims that there's free no speech it's
due for foreigners into thinking
that we are democratic and that because
you know totalitarian North Korean issue
communist were no like
democratic oh the
world like and that's the thing America
you guys Canada America Melbourne
whatever the you guys have freedom
speech but your politicians aren't able
to articulate what actually freedom
speech is which is why distinct for
government is able to manipulate it in
that way because essentially what
freedom of speech is is I haven't seen
anybody articulate this before so you're
gonna get exclusive but the central
aspect of freedom speech really is
immunity from the law even if you piss
people off with your words even if I
specifically make a comment some people
deep even if I specifically make a
comment that okay Lisa and long which is
the current dictator on country rapes
children everyday or I tell people to
murder every Christian or a
Muslim in the world so that atheism can
rise I should not be trapped for them
that is freedom speech right so I guess
I guess some people would say if you
were to say that the latter thing which
is you know I
want to murder all these peoples or a
theater can rise then there's sort of a
direct threat so I guess there's a
little bit of a gray area there but but
you're more of an absolutist you think
no matter what you think the director
yeah even if this is like a direct
threat why I say that because that's
thing I tell you to kill all those
Christian I'm not I don't
want to do that by the way that's not a
good way to but I tell you kill all
those Christian and Isis
somewhat Dean but but but then you go
out and kill somebody and you cause a
riot it's your responsibility that you
listen to my words and act upon it it's
not my responsibility
right so so is so if I cost so in my
words causes people to create a riot
that's their responsibility they go to
jail I don't I shouldn't be charged for
that right so you're making the
distinction obviously between words and
actions so if there was somebody look
I've seen a couple videos where people
that don't like you have you know
attacked you in a mall and I saw you got
some somebody grabbed you in a store and
in front of a lot of people that just
kind of watched it happens so if there
was somebody right now that was watching
your videos that lived down the block
from you and then they started telling
people oh kill a mostly kill a mostly
you're saying you would be you would
actually before they're right to say
that but but you would be against
obviously the person that would come to
kill Amos each other people actually
kills Amos Eve please don't kill a Missy
you have to make that qualification
there yeah okay so so what's next so
you're out now when is the next trial
what can people do to help awareness I
think we're doing a little something
here but what can we do what can you
guys do the biggest things you can do is
just spread the word hashtag Freeman
Amos II make videos make blog posts say
write your feelings about it and share
my videos my videos are great yeah
really great really I don't be
arrogant but really it they're great
it's not even being around it's just
stating facts they're great
so share my videos especially yeah they
just spread awareness and I don't know
maybe if you guys start campaigns start
Facebook pages what
you guys know the platform since spread
awareness so do that on the Internet and
if you know people like a much more um
you know live kind of action I don't
know maybe make speeches or protests on
the streets or something in front of
this Singaporean Embassy which is what
the Hong Kong people in Taiwan these
people did it before before that when I
was sent to jail now now now I found out
that the goddamn the Singapore the Hong
Kong I think Taiwan people they're not
hunting me all the NGOs and human rights
and the activists who talked who spoke
up to me before they don't want to speak
up with me anymore because you see
that's the thing
before that I was charged for it was
very blatantly obvious that I was sent
to jail because because there was a
political agenda because I mocked Lee
Kuan Yew but I add a little Christian
quote in between that's why it gave the
government a reason for them to charge
me mm-hmm but but mock dictator it's
alright but not religion oh then you're
being too rude and because of that then
now popularity is all-time low in
Singapore nobody likes me in the same
for it's a hell out there I go out I get
attacked you saw the footage Ruben
so yeah which is why I uh George vibes
like really depressing I'm like oh my
gosh I'm gonna lose I'm gonna go to jail
nobody's gonna talk about it then logic
came along then dusty came along then
you came along so alright so we know all
about the the videos of people attacking
you you just said your popularity is at
an all-time low in Singapore but I'm
guessing that in a society that's as
repressed and oppressed as you describe
it that there's probably a lot of people
who actually are rooting for you do you
get people coming up to you privately or
sending you messages or tweets or
whatever from Singapore that are
secretly trying to push you along and
happy about what you're doing good they
say something good about me is I'm
popular and you know there's really lots
of peer pressure and I think that's the
same thing in every kind of society you
know you go to all the goddamn Facebook
sites like all Singapore stuff or you
know you know all Singapore stuff or
like the independence and you know all
of them we're like singing there's
she was seen for an audience and
basically whenever my news comes off he
just bashed me he just bashed me and
nobody wants to say anything good about
me even though they might like me so
yeah it's just unpopular same stuff
that's good about me so well privately
and publicly yeah so if you could get
out right this moment I mean if you had
a golden ticket right this second would
you want to leave what I want to leave
I'm not going to tell you because there
are yeah I'm not gonna say because that
might dictate the judge's decision
somebody yeah basically they're gonna do
the things that opposite from my from
what I want but you see that's the thing
if I go if I go overseas and then I
leave the country right not because you
making anti-religious videos and then
continue continuing the atheist
revolution and you know be free and
obviously not go to a cell which is
horrible but if I go to a cell
not to say that I won't get any
attention if I'm not in a cell
I'm still interesting regardless if I'm
put into a cell there's much more
awareness because you know oh my god
somebody's sent to a cell somebody is
you know put in prison there's much more
of an incentive for people to talk about
it get protests you know you know make
raise awareness all that good stuff so
that's the thing whether they kill me
put me in a Cell let me go immediately
I don't wait they're so I'm
winning such an advantageous position
nobody in Singapore has ever been that
advantageous before every opposition
politicians fail because they're never
in such an advantageous position as me
so you can you can kill a man but you
can't kill an idea I think that's what
you're saying so what do you think is
gonna happen if you if you had to just
guess so when are you going back I was
trying to figure that out
when's the next day the next trial day
or the next day in court I mean in two
weeks there's still gonna be a pre-trial
which is like yeah after that like in a
few more weeks later doesn't
so gonna be stretched out for about I
don't know a few months before I get my
sentence and get sent to jail I'm pretty
sure that I'll be sent to jail I don't
know what are they say are they saying
to you if you retract some of this or if
you take the videos down or blah blah
blah that will let you go is there any
like is there any negotiation like what
are they trying to do
cuz you see that's the thing PAP has
been ruling the country for goddamn 50
years and they just got their mandate
did you've got 70% of the goddamn vote
in goddamn Singapore which is absolutely
horrible and the first year after they
get their goddamn mandate is when they
have all the atrocities you know
they're I mean right now they're they're
charging there they just gave a goddamn
death sentence - this guy called koja
Bing and everybody's goddamn you
know shocked and then right now there's
this thing called there's this
ridiculous thing where a day before the
time when you vote cooling-off day you
can't goddamn write any articles online
which might distinct the you know
differentiate it vote even though the
mainstream media can and then
these opposition people Roy young and
kill so long they're being charged for
that right now they're being sent to
jail they're the police are raiding
their house this is the time the
first year after the goddamn Singapore
government gets the mandate is when they
do all these atrocious things so
this is yeah and which is why it's a
good time to play the game they're doing
all these atrocities he decided to trust
me after they get their mandate
so they want to play hard let's give a
little credit to your mom she's walked
back and forth a couple of times so when
you when she finds out about all this
stuff and right now she hears you in the
other room and you're passionate and
you're going on about all this stuff she
she still I know I'm sure that your mom
doesn't want you to be in jail so what
are the discussions with you guys like
does she say she just says do whatever
you want is there any level of tone it
down or of course she tries to urge me
to tone it down she tried to urge me
because she thinks she's like all other
people she's like oh no you know don't
be rude don't be offensive get your
points across people listen to you more
and you know
that kind of thing you know because you
know she's a goddamn she's the Asian mom
you know that's the thing but but before
that she was just like yeah she was just
like disappointed pissed um now she is
really being like I don't know kind of
like convinced we're saying you know
free Emma see I I disagree with this
approach but you should not send him to
jail for it so that's the good thing
about my mom yeah yeah and concerning
the approach of being vulgar and
stuff yeah people make the argument okay
if you toned down evolve a language and
all of that more people would support
you and you'll get a bigger audience
more people take you seriously I don't
think so actually
because you see you lose a huge portion
of my audience when you use bubble
language but right now we're in the
Internet age where essentially vulgar
language and they already like top
youtubers PewDiePie and whoever they're
all using vulgar language not to say
that PewDiePie is good sucks
then you really do fight the power it's
one thing to fight the state and fight
religion but to fight booty by that's
big anyways you gain okay you gain a
much larger audience with the whole with
using vulgar language very eloquently
and skillfully so the amount I gain I
think for now is yeah it's much more
than the amount I lose so we're supposed
to still continue to do it but things
that create a huge range I mean video
called how to destroy Singapore
government where's essentially it's less
vulgar it's much more putting points
across and now I make the greatest anti
Christian video where it's essentially
vulgar as hell you know funny
like that's great so yeah so yeah I make
the whole spectrum I gain the whole
spectrum of the audience you know
sometimes I make a new video all people
don't like me out and people like me and
that's what makes relationships good
Ruben you piss them off they like you
again do survive that's what makes life
fun Ruben yeah I mean that's what it's
all about right like do what you think
you should do and you know people like
me have to help defend people like you
and amplify your voice so I hope that's
what we did here do you you have a
closing statement I know there's you
don't hold anything back I feel like you
may know it may not even have anything
left
you got a closing statement for me
the government let's destroy him Lisa
and long that's the main target that's
the guy it's essentially he dictates all
the laws in Singapore let's bash him out
let's bash that up
he's the one that's charging me he's the
ones that's causing all of this
he's the one that's imprisoning atheists
in Singapore he's the one that's causing
the worst country in the world let's
destroy him let's advocate for God and
philosophy and signs and all that good
freedom speech stuff man don't listen
you absolutely have an ally in me I
promise you that it's hashtag save a
mistake free moc I'm starting another
hashtag for you there you go and just
from our we're gonna put the links down
below but remind everyone where they can
find you online all right man seriously
you're a brave warrior for all the right
things and anything I can do for you
please let me know